that smiley face is looking at me man
hello cannonball oh my I think I can
push myself off Oh was I supposed to do
something here was I supposed to be
spring spawning on ropes and whatnot
supposed to do that excess the Aston
Scooby speaker moves I did it I did it
indeed I did indeed do it I did whoop
whoop
I won it's an impossible road
we'll see how impossible it is well I
guess I'll see how impossible it is
there's no more than unusal bad
well I don't know why that I need to
stop here I'm just gonna go on my merry
way now there we go was that a quick
sweep off that I ain't afraid of you
little boys out here thanks little booth
but what what oh my ninja training now
this is a polka of course I get out now
let's not oh we did it again there we go
part of it Oh God can we not what did I
just say how about we don't or if you
died there I would have been very upset
Oh what's this some kicky doodads stupid
asses whoa wow I didn't know it's going
on this ride oh I can't say this is what
you deserve man I got it how are you
supposed to get Pat look at Suzie this
oh my I just killed you to save you from
the horrible aliens don't blame me
please don't blame me
Wow Wow a lien jeez Wow
that's oh my goodness Chris everybody
please excuse me as I try to avoid
aliens knife throw hands and we embrace
the sweet
- this love story nyan survival any
character where you made me beat never
mind you know what never mind okay I
have a charge last about this but that's
okay
godson hurt oh my I'm still alive oh I'm
flying why am i full oh my this is not a
good sign
ah oh I just water just system poor no
freeze wall what does that mean how did
you do that I'm actually curious how did
this do one oh my oh excuse me just easy
to move my head 90 degrees to the side
oh that's so cool let me do that I've
never seen anything like this oh my this
is actually something original in happy
wheels that even a thing ow ow ow
at least oh my oh my oh my and knock it
down or up that's good enough I like
this this is okay oh I got indeed uber
actor Nova ow
he's dieted your pain with some yoga
what the hell is snooker
taug run by i'm inflate the old guy in
forever oh I guess I won't be playing
him anymore oh my god well he didn't
know oh my god
fly fly fly like the wind and birds and
things why like you never had meaning of
fly you're right there man
oh I still 100 K ninja test through
stupid enjoy the movie well I got places
to be in Omaha hurry so if you can stop
being such [ __ ] for like to deck it
out I'm not digging around this time get
out of my way I'm gonna make you boy I
would my way take my kid and I'm just
done with your baloney
ah malarkey I'm gonna beat you nope let
me to move it's a ball for throw so a
sport ball throw the ball throw of all
epic rump wing man is so gnarly bro 99
impossible oh my god I think that counts
as a win epic arrow run everything oh I
didn't know this is the one oh please
stop arrowing my ass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wrecking ball run well to this day I
ain't afraid of no wrecking ball wildly
we're gonna have any blow this Sal loses
hat all right please we're on a wrecking
ball run with we live we live there go
it quit instantly why not like the laces
so that we don't get in any trouble it's
over clinging for bad citizens don't let
me die this time I keep feeling the
brains breathe rushing bye-bye hat but I
don't think there's anything to worry
about today
damn kid looky bloody we got it load it
all over you know I reserved getting it
blown it all over
Ferrari slurs like noises it's an epic
era oh my oh my that was not a tear oh
oh this one might actually be kind of
hard
how do you win there is no way to win
has got to be away maybe the answer is
falling face-first
I'm gonna win I am I'm gonna win I'm
gonna what the secret is to fly the
secret is to flip flop fly didn't make
the sound i won oh I got it
wait oh that was a mistake oh not my
nards
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna kill myself I'm gonna do it
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like the
video and want to see more why not
subscribe today want to help the channel
grow
leave a like add it to your favorites
will share with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video
like a weight by elf yes yeah go get out
of here yeah here yeah yeah good idea
across this
I love this one I love this don't make
me laugh here that time